[Music]
my dad always told me
99 of being a parent is showing up for
your kids
this from a man who deferred countless
promotions to be sure that he came home
for dinner every night
and echoed by my mom who gave up her
career to raise me
and my sisters in our family
we hug until the other person lets go
and then just a little bit longer as a
reminder that the best part
of any relationship comes from that
choice
to show up to stay
today we're experiencing the opposite an
epidemic of leaving
social media is filled with white flags
of people giving up
surrendering unfriend me if you don't
support x i don't want to be friends
with anyone who believes why
decades long relationships with
colleagues and friends even siblings
gone
with a simple declaration but what's
possible when we stay
in those difficult conversations
relationships with tension between
ourselves and others
every week we hear stories of friends
muting blocking unfriending each other
on social media
and cancel culture it makes it almost
impossible to have relationships across
difference
when your gut says to disavow a
childhood friend
to leave behind a hometown to cut and
run
i want to challenge you today to ask
what's possible
when we stay
catholicism to me is an ethnicity i was
born into it
in my community we used to trade gossip
about priests sunday sermons the way
that some
trade highlights about fantasy football
leagues and in my family
we prayed to saints for everything from
world peace
to help finding a parking space the
single
monolithic experience of the catholic
church touched
everything and everyone in my life
so when at eight years old i realized
that i was gay
i hid that shame like a tattoo
a permanent reminder that i was
different
that i didn't belong in 28 years and two
decades of catholic education
i've experienced continuous intense
opposition to my place in the catholic
church
i've been called a [ __ ] by my priest
i've been spat on leaving church
multiple times
and in one singing memory
had a teacher tell me to go to hell in
front of her class of second graders
but i've also experienced the exact
opposite reaction too
the very first time that i came out i
was in an indiana wendy's
sitting across from a priest who called
my gayness
a gift from god my superpower
i still have friends and family who
believe that i don't have a place in the
church
but i do belong lgbtq
people have always been a part of the
church and always will be
i choose to stay in the church for the
handful of people for whom my presence
on sundays
will be the religious experience that
they have that week
and when i walk into a church with my
head held high
holding my boyfriend's hand i get to be
the change that i always wanted to see
and for a queer kid like me wondering
hoping even praying for some sign of
belonging
that would have changed my world
sometimes our decision to stay is less
about our identity and more about how we
choose to show up for friends
at the height of the 2014 war in gaza
i worked as a summer counselor at a camp
dedicated to conflict resolution
between palestinians and israelis
camp was founded on this extraordinarily
simple idea
that maintaining friendships across
difference could make all the difference
teens eight slept played sports together
chairs were thrown yelling was frequent
but never
did tears run more freely than when camp
ended hugs between sides
literally lasted minutes
over the years camp alumni communication
channels once so effusive and friendly
grew volatile with time and then silent
but
under the surface were incredible
stories
of lives changed even saved because
friends made the decision to show up for
each other
in may of 2019 when violence spiked
again
in gaza a palestinian man placed a call
to a commander in the israeli defense
forces
with a single request please
protect my family his former camp mate
replied of course my friend
they will be safe
what makes these moments so impactful
is not just the decision to pick up the
phone
to reach out it's also on the other side
about how we choose to answer the call
while working at nbc news i often
received
a very different type of call
in our age of political polarization
death threats from angry viewers were
frequent
and some were spine chillingly specific
i grew used to hanging up on hundreds of
different calls with an instinctual
click
until one day one unusual day
i heard something and decided to stay on
the line
i remember the rage and the yelling even
before the receiver hit my ear
but then i heard yelled a familiar
town name travis was from iowa but not
just
iowa a tiny little town not 30 minutes
from where my dad grew up
and where i used to spend holidays with
my grandma
and so while he was yelling i built up
some courage
and i threw out casually i thought you
don't happen to know happy joe's pizza
do you
silence and then he started laughing
in true midwestern fashion with zero
explanation at all
we went from ranting about politics to
raving about a local pizza joint that we
both love
another day another caller melanie is
from kansas
we quickly learned on the phone that she
loves profanity and she hates socialism
but this time i started asking her
questions trying to understand her anger
we discovered that she and my mom were
both preschool teachers
and that was a huge relief for her thank
god you get it
and truly i did last month i had the
surreal pleasure
of wishing melanie happy birthday on
facebook where we're now friends
a very frequent caller used to call and
ask for the gay one
hi john i would say answering the phone
john had recently moved to an assisted
living home by his family
and once we got past his homophobia he
mostly wanted to just talk about college
football with someone who would listen
this past fall john's grandson came out
and surprisingly he reached out to me
looking to understand how he could
support
after our back and forth i believe john
will stay
if only for his family
i wish standing here that i could tell
you with these examples that staying is
easy
it's not it's messy it's unpredictable
and often
it's not without great personal cost and
as
such it's easier to believe that our
lives
are better when we cut and run
but are they better or are they truly
just
easier too often i feel we make the easy
choice we see
something and we're triggered we get
angry we grab our phones and type
if you don't believe what i have to say
unfriend me shut the hell up
anger is easy the alternative is what's
harder
and maybe that's all it takes one person
who makes a different choice
i want you to imagine with me a
different
world where the choice to stay is our
first
instinct where we grow together
instead of a part where we reach out
instead of lash out
where we make the decision to show up
for other people
with the understanding that by doing so
we increase the likelihood that they
show up for us
because isn't that what we all want at
the end of the day
what is possible when we say
the answer is everything
but you won't know unless you try
thank you